fast fashion billig hergestellt kurz
getragen schnell entsorgt das glück
trendbewusste teenager wenn etwas neues
hast kriegst dem kleinen brüsten das
immer so ein glücksgefühl konsum ohne
reue
die textilen es verschafft durch fast
fashion eine ganze generation zu fashion
jobs zu machen
die kundschaft ist kritischer geworden
die branche reagiert und verspricht
recycling als lösung wohl auch um das
gewissen der käufer zu beruhigen und
kameras so nennen dass es eigentlich
einen vorspielung einer falschen
tatsache ist kleidung zu kleidung
recycling findet so gut wie nicht statt
große mengen der schnellen mode landen
in ländern wie bulgarien und werden zum
problem der letzte rest der kleidung
wird von den ernsten verfeuert wir haben
kein geld um brennholz zu kaufen
die verbrannten textilien verpesten die
atemluft wenn ihr wille der kleider
enthalten einen erheblichen anteil von
kunststoff und ähnlichem
das ist der geruch von krankheit
zdfzoom will wissen was bleibt vom
nachhaltigkeit versprechen der fast
fashion hersteller
[Musik]
es ist lockdown die läden sind
geschlossen
in normalen zeiten beherrschen fast
fashion ketten wie h&m zara primark und
andere unsere innenstädte in corona
zeiten bleibt vieles in den regalen
liegen doch shoppen geht trotzdem online
fast fashion hat die textil branche
umgekrempelt und das tempo der mode
rasant erhöht
worin liegt der reiz ständig neues zu
haben
in wiesbaden besuche ich zwei echte fast
fashion fans mischen und elena sind
mitte zwanzig und angehende
psychotherapeutinnen mode ist ihr hobby
und ein kostspieliges dazu heute suchen
sie online nach kleidern hosen und
pullover glaubte spitze was anziehen was
ich hin kommt drauf an unis am ende
ausfällt kann es ja zurückschicken ich
werde die beiden wieder besuchen wenn
die bestellung da ist wer zeigt ihnen
die neuesten trends
das ist auf jeden fall social media ganz
großer faktor ist instagram die ganzen
influenza die machen wirklich so extrem
viel werbung und man will sich davon
eigentlich gar nicht so beeinflussen
lassen aber im endeffekt wenn ich jeden
tag immer empfiehlt das gleiche oberteil
sehe uns dann immer noch verlinken zu
meistens mit dem online-shop internet
und social media befeuern das tempo der
mode
in florenz erinnen mit eigenen
youtube-kanal rufen täglich neue trends
aus und präsentieren schnippchen
das ist öl ins feuer der fast fashion
mit bis zu einer million followern haben
manche in florenz erinnen eine echte
werbe macht
das jetzt mal anprobiert das ganze gut
[Musik]
gab es früher vier kollektionen im jahr
bringen es billig ketten wie h&m zara
und primark inzwischen auf bis zu 52
micro kollektionen jede woche eine neue
der verkauf neuer kleidung hat sich seit
dem jahr 2000 verdoppelt
mehr als 120 milliarden kleidungsstücke
werden global pro jahr produziert die
welt ist im klamotten rausch noch einmal
besuche ich mich schnell und elena die
georderte kleidung ist da jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt
die beiden haben quer durch alle shops
bestellt 26 kilo kleidung pro jahr pro
person kaufen die deutschen die
lebensdauer der textilien wird immer
kürzer im schnitt 1,7 mal wird ein paar
top getragen bevor es aussortiert wird
rund 40 prozent der kleidung wird nie
angezogen so eine us-studie
wie lange hält denn jetzt dieses gefühl
dieses schöne
ja ich habe jetzt hier ganz viele neue
sachen ehrlich zu sein bei sowas hätten
thaksins ankommt und wenn es mir
angucken kann aber viel länger hält der
gix momentan auch nicht
michelle zeigt mir ihren kleiderschrank
sie braucht platz für die neuen sachen
welche teile zieht sie überhaupt dran
hier ist ein sommer teil noch das ist
doch total zerknittert das kann auf
jeden fall weg wird kann ich auch
aussortieren sich auch gar nicht mehr so
graf auch von sarah das ist zum beispiel
so war es total sie ist hätte ich den
sommer aber einmal maximal an schöne
farbe aber ich ziehe es wirklich nieren
schau mal ich hab einfach sachen sogar
mit preisschild weil das ist auch kein
einzelstück
ich habe hier auch nach was hier ist
noch ein preisschild dran
ich glaube ich jetzt sogar glaube ich
jetzt auch noch ein preisschild dran
wir finden jede menge schrank leichen
bei h&m gibt es inzwischen die
möglichkeit altkleider zurückzubringen
und direkt wurde mir vor der tür und da
habe ich jetzt auch schon mal was
abgegeben wo es dann hin kommt weiß man
ja auch das was passiert mit michelles
klamotten wenn sie sie bei h&m abgibt
dieser frage gehe ich nach seit 2013
kann man bei h&m aussortierte textilien
in einem altkleider tonne werfen
sarah c&a und andere ziehen nach und
stellen auch container auf das
versprechen aus den alten kleidern
werden neue textilien gemacht zwei tüten
pro kunde und taten im 1000 m an
dafür gibt es 15 prozent rabatt als
anreiz für den nächsten einkauf
die aktion kommt an allein bei h&m
wurden 2016 16.000 tonnen altkleider
eingesammelt 2009 10 waren es schon
29.000 tonnen weltweit die fast fashion
anbieter arbeiten an einem besseren
image und preisen ihre recycling
bemühungen ressourcenverschwendung war
gestern schocken und wegwerfen ist kein
problem
wir machen aus eurem müll neue kleidung
um einen kreislauf zu bekommen ist es
entscheidend sicherzustellen dass alle
produkte im zyklus bleiben so dass sie
wieder und wieder verwendet werden
können die werbung verspricht schöne
neue mode aus alttextilien ich bestelle
bei h&m und zara als nachhaltig
deklarierte kleidung und stoße auf ein
begriffs wirrwar was heißt nachhaltig
was heißt recycelt
in der hochschule reutlingen treffe ich
einen textil fachmann der die
modeindustrie seit jahren beobachtet ich
bringe ihm die aussortierten teile aus
michelles kleiderschrank kein nebel vom
institut für textil und design kennt
sich aus mit kleidung lässt sich daraus
durch recycling was neues machen
das sind zwei verschiedene stoffe fühlt
man auch gleich schon das ist polyamid
und viskose das ist also schon eine
schwierige kombination rund 70 prozent
aller neu produzierten textilien
bestehen aus synthetischen fasern
sie werden aus rohöl gewonnen und sind
schlecht wieder verwertbar
wenn ich da im laden mit ihr schon
kreislauf suggeriert und ich denke
natürlich machen die aus meinen alten
klamotten irgendwas schickes neues
es kann ruhig so nennen das ist
eigentlich ein vorspiel um einer
falschen tatsache ist also wenn ich dann
von recycling spreche ja auch wenn man
später auf die deklaration guckt da ist
ein recycling anteil drin wo der
herkommt ist gar nicht genau festgelegt
und er kommt sage ich mal zu 99,9
prozent nicht aus altheim kleidung zu
kleidung recycling findet so gut wie
nicht statt wenn aus altkleidern gar
keine neue mode werden kann
was ist dann drin in den angeblich
nachhaltigen teilen die ich gekauft habe
auf dem etikett steht 25 prozent
recyceltes polyester
genauere angaben sind schwer zu finden
erst im online-store stoße ich auf mehr
informationen zu der hose aus der join
live reihe von zara hier steht es ist
ein teilweise recycelter anteil im
polyester anteil der hose enthalten
natürlich verwirrend und wenn wenn wir
auch steht dann zertifizierungen global
recycelt standard content standard es
steht da nur
es ist also nicht es ist kein zertifikat
erkennbar und auch selbst diese
standards sagen nicht sehr viel aus sie
sagen auch nur aus das recyclingmaterial
drin ist sein könnte aber eben nichts
konkret ist und nicht nachvollziehbar
ist also da fehlt die transparenz
wir fragen bei zara nach warum die
angaben so verwirrend sind für zara
scheint die sache klar
das unternehmen schreibt wir möchten
klarstellen dass sich die prozentangaben
auf den german life etiketten auf das
gesamte kleidungsstück beziehen
mit anderen worten in dem von ihnen
erwähnten fall sind mindestens 25
prozent des gesamten rohmaterials dieses
produkts recyceltes polyester und wie
hoch ist der anteil wieder verwerteter
kleidung in der hose
darauf gibt uns sarah keine konkrete
antwort schluss fragen wollen im grunde
aus diesen alten sachen die man zurück
gegeben hat dann diese mit recycle
materialien versehenen neuen sachen
machen könnte also man kann sicherlich
nicht pauschal aus dem klamotten kaufen
neue kleidung machen diese textilien
sind aus alten flaschen sind aus
plastikflaschen nicht aus textilien also
damit kann ich recycling mäßig nichts
anfangen
kein nebel stellt fest in den als
nachhaltig deklarierten textilien ist so
gut wie keine recycelte kleidung
enthalten und aus den textil gemischen
unserer aussortierten fast fashion lässt
sich keine neue kleidung machen
wir fragen bei h&m nach und kriegen als
antwort nur angaben zu dem recycling
anteil der aus kunststoffen gewonnen
wurde aber nicht zu dem aus alter
kleidung h&m schreibt wie bereits
beschrieben stammen die materialien aus
unterschiedlichen quellen und sind dabei
abhängig vom rohstoff sowie der
spezifischen kollektion
beispielsweise wurden in h&m konnte
exclusive collections bereits zu 100
recyceltes polyester eingesetzt
recyceltes polyester jahr aber wie hoch
der anteil recycelter kleidung in den
neuen textilien ist sagt uns h&m nicht
aber was passiert dann mit den sachen
aus dem container bei h&m wenn daraus
keine neue kleidung wird
h&m arbeitet mit der firma ecolog
zusammen ein subunternehmen von sechs
deutschlands größtem textil verwertern
hier lernten die textil säcke aus den
hunt m tonnen auf demselben sortier berg
wie altkleider anderer sammlungen nur
die besten teile werden als secondhand
ware wieder verkauft die schlechteren
qualitäten gehen ins recycling und
werden höchstens zudem materialien oder
lappen
damit finanziert sich das system selbst
meine aussortierte fast fashion wird
also bestenfalls zum putztuch was
passiert wenn immer mehr fast fashion
mit immer schlechterer qualität bei den
text tiefer wert an landet ich treffe
thomas fischer vom bundesverband
sekundärrohstoffe und entsorgung er
kennt die klagen der sortier betriebe
über die massen der fast fashion
die qualität der ware ist ein
entscheidendes kriterium wie dann
weiterverkaufen kann und die hochwertige
und die qualitative kleidung ist umso
höher ist der erlös den ich aus der
sortierung heraus und weiterverkauf
erziele
die frage ist wie ist das ganze system
noch zu bezahlen
und je mehr schnell booten ebenso mode
kommt die qualität tiefer runter gehen
umso kleiner wird diese marken und
irgendwann ist es dann vermeiden und ob
dann bis dann dieser punkt erreicht ist
dann vergehen vielleicht noch mal drei
vier fünf oder zehn jahre bei irgendwann
ist dann überrollt es sich selbst an wie
eine lawine
ein großer teil der altec stelian wird
von den sortier betrieben ins ausland
weiterverkauft immer größere mengen
landen in osteuropa in ländern wie polen
rumänien und bulgarien
wenn große mengen textil reste nach
osteuropa gehen was passiert dort damit
bei meinen recherchen stoße ich auf
beiträge des bulgarischen fernsehens ich
sehe erstaunliches altkleider reste
sollen dort in haushalten verfeuert
werden
der bericht zeigt schwarze schafe der
altkleider branche verkaufen textil
reste an die arme bevölkerung zum heizen
für umgerechnet 30 euro die tonne
wir haben hier klamotten taschen mützen
schuhe kleiderreste die sich nicht zum
recycling eigenen müssen in bulgarien
laut gesetz in speziell ausgerüsteten
verbrennungsanlagen kostenpflichtig
vernichtet werden um diese kosten zu
sparen verkaufen einige sortier betriebe
die textil reste lieber weiter ein
freund hat mir den tipp gegeben hier
gäbe es kleiderreste
ich brauche sie zum verbrennen ich kann
den tipp geben was noch viel besser ist
als kleidung lieber schuhe
sie brennen viel besser die sind
hochkalorische weil sie mehr
synthetische stoffe beinhalten
ich reise selbst nach sofia wo landen
die textilien aus westeuropa und was
passiert dort mit ihnen die fast fashion
hersteller geben vor aus alt neu zu
machen
in den industriegebieten am stadtrand
von sophia mache ich mich auf die suche
nach händlern für textil reste
alttextilien aus deutschland verspricht
das schild doch heute gibt es hier nicht
zu kaufen
[Musik]
ich treffe jemanden der sich auskennt in
der branche in bulgarien er will anonym
bleiben
ich bitte ihn mir zu helfen ausgestattet
mit einer brillen kamera will er mir
säcke mit kleider resten besorgen
er macht sich auf den weg zu einer
verkaufsstelle für textil reste ich war
gerade in der gegend und wollte
kleidersäcke holen habt ihr noch welche
ich nehme 2 ich habe gehört dass man
hier auch schon mal kleidung zum heizen
kaufen konnte brent kleidung denn gut es
war schon mal jemand da der hat kleidung
zum heizen gekauft das ist wahnsinn was
war das für eine er hatte uns gesagt das
sei für eine autowerkstatt und später
hat er dann erzählt dass er sie zum
verbrennen braucht wieder zurück am
treffpunkt übergibt mir mein informant
die kleidersäcke ich frage ihn wer kauft
normalerweise sowas und wird damit
geheizt
[Musik]
diese säcke werden vor allem von sozial
schwachen sehr armen leuten gekauft den
stadtvierteln wohnen mit denen man noch
nicht einmal mit zentralheizung oder
strom
die meisten die dort wohnen haben alte
holz für diese menschen ist es offenbar
günstiger von einem secondhand lager
kleiderreste für wenig geld zu kaufen
und damit halten sie dann
ich werde die säcke mitnehmen nach
deutschland um herauszufinden welche
stoffe in den alltag stelian enthalten
sind und welche chemischen verbindungen
beim verbrennen freigesetzt werden
alttextilien als heiz kleidung sind der
illegale weg zur entsorgung auf legalem
wege werden altkleider für den
bulgarischen secondhandmarkt sortiert
und weiterverkauft
am stadtrand von sophia betreibt das
schweizer unternehmen texaid ein so berg
hier dürfen wir drehen sales managerin
alina war nova führt uns durchs werk im
betrieb landen textilien aus kleider
containern in deutschland der schweiz
und skandinavien bis zu 25 tonnen
sortieren sie hier täglich in
unterschiedliche qualitäten mit dem ziel
möglichst viele gut erhaltene kleidung
zum weiterverkauf zu haben
doch die flut der meist minderwertigen
fast fashion macht diese rechnung
zunichte jedes jahr merken wir dass die
hochwertige ware immer weniger wird die
fast fashion wird dafür mehr
früher konnten wir mehr textilien
weiterverwerten heute können wir immer
mehr kleidung überhaupt nicht nutzen
die kleidung mit guter qualität wird
immer weniger
was ist das problem mit der qualität der
fast fashion
das material ist das problem die
verarbeitung ist das problem
es ist modisch aber die sachen haben nur
eine kurze haltbarkeit
das meiste davon müssen wir aussortieren
zum recycling und selbst fürs recycling
taugen die sachen nicht weil sie nicht
aus baumwolle sind
ich habe herausgefunden fast fashion
taucht oft nicht zur weiterverwertung
sondern muss kostenpflichtig entsorgt
werden
schwarze schafe verkaufen die reste
illegal zum heizen
ich fahre nach fakultät einem roma
viertel in sofia einige häuser haben
weder strom wasser und heizung die
meisten heizen mit holz kohle oder pence
ich treffe die sozialarbeiterin sony das
trikot war
kontakt zu einer roma familie will sie
nicht herstellen
weil sich die bewohner oft vorgeführt
fühlen ich frage sie ob sie gesehen hat
dass hier textilien verbrannt werden
in all den jahren die ich hier arbeite
habe ich es ab und an gesehen zum
beispiel im heizofen im haus es kommt
immer mal wieder vor dass am ofen aus
kleider verbrannt werden
die bulgarischen winter sind kalt laut
einer studie der eu ist bulgarien
europaweit das land mit der höchsten
zahl an kindern die in ungeheizten
räumen schlafen wenn der winter kalt ist
so wie vor zwei wochen mit schnee und
minusgraden dann damit du das eine
zimmer dass du hast ich würde es nicht
mal ein zimmer nennen irgendwie warm
bekommst dann steckst du in den ofen was
du gerade finden kannst um ein kleines
bisschen wärme zu erzeugen
sofia hat ein luft problem
müllverbrennung es neben auto- und
industrieabgasen eine weitere ursache
der luftverschmutzung lese ich die stadt
ist in europa die metropole mit der
stärksten luftverschmutzung überhaupt
ist daran auch die in haushalts öfen
verbrannte kleidung schuld dr alexanders
im xf ist facharzt für lungenkrankheiten
am medizinischen institut des
innenministeriums seit jahren untersucht
er den zusammenhang von
luftverschmutzung und gesundheitsschäden
in sofia das ist der geruch von
krankheit viele der kleider enthalten
einen erheblichen anteil von
verformbaren kunststoff plastik und
ähnlichen wenn das verbrannt wird
entsteht eine menge leicht flüchtiger
organischer verbindungen neben anderen
dingen dann gibt es dann auch probleme
mit stickoxid und schwefeldioxid viele
dieser stoffe verbinden sich mit der
übrigen verschmutzung sie sind also kein
kleiner sonne an erheblicher teil und
welche auswirkungen hat das auf die
gesundheit der menschen
wenn wir ein hohes maß an verschmutzung
haben verzeichnen wir mehr
lungeninfektionen andere folgen sind
stressreaktionen wie zum beispiel
erhöhter blutdruck mehr schlaganfälle
das ist eine neurologische
komplikationen all das kann auftreten
bis zu 24 stunden nachdem man eine
erhöhten luftverschmutzung ausgesetzt
war
soviel kämpft mit schadstoffen in der
luft und die haushaltshilfen scheinen
daran einen anteil zu haben
was ist drin in den säcken die ich
gekauft habe
es sind zerschnittene shirts viele mit
kunststoff aufdruck immer wieder
begegnen mir bekannte etiketten von zara
h&m und anderen fast fashion brands
zurück in deutschland schicke ich die
kleidung zur analyse zum bremer
umweltinstitut ulrike siemers untersucht
ihre zusammensetzung
wir haben eine bunte mischung an proben
gekriegt es waren auch einige dabei die
skifahren enthalten die projekte halte
ich zb waren oder aber auch andere
chemiefaser anteile besaßen
das waren zum teil textilien die gefärbt
waren es waren ungefähr dabei und viele
die eben auch ein aufdruck hatten
der test soll zeigen ob durch die
verbrennung der textilien giftige
verbindungen entstehen können
verfärbt sich die flamme ist die probe
positiv wenn halogenierte verbindung
gefunden werden hinweise darauf
dann kann es sein speziell die
chlorierten verbindungen bei
verbrennungsprozessen sogenannte dioxine
entstehen können und dies gelten als
krebserregend und gesundheitsschädigend
wenn solche stoffe durch undichte
heizöfen in den innenraum entweichen und
direkt eingeatmet werden sind sie
besonders schädlich
[Musik]
umweltschutzorganisationen betrachten
die negativen auswirkungen des
zunehmenden fast fashion mülls mit sorge
in hamburg treffe ich viola wohlgemuth
bei greenpeace zuständig für konsum und
ressourcenschutz
sie fordert ein schnelles und
entschlossenes politisches handeln
firmen werden freiwillig nicht ihr
business modell ändern wir brauchen
gesetzliche rahmen und durchsetzung das
ist jetzt wichtig sonst werden wir es
nicht schaffen dass wir im rahmen dieser
klimakrise mit so etwas banalem wie am
über konsum von klamotten weitermachen
können
warum gibt es nicht schon längst strenge
rahmenbedingungen für die produktion von
textilien
das frage ich den parlamentarischen
staatssekretär im
bundesumweltministerium florian pronold
die modeketten müssen ihr verhalten
verändern
ich glaube dass der zentrale punkt in so
einem großen markt ist wie europa dass
man tatsächlich vorschriften macht über
die art und weise wie produkte designt
werden die bei uns auf den markt kommen
und das ist der dreh und angelpunkt das
wenn auch nach wie vor viele kommen dass
man sie zumindest recyceln kann dass sie
eine entsprechende qualität haben dass
man weiß was da drin ist aber das ist ja
einen prozess der schon seit einigen
jahren und ganz wie sowieso ist man da
kann man nicht schneller und massiver
wir kämpfen mit dafür dass es ende des
jahres eine eu-weite textil strategie
gibt die genau das machen kann weil wir
als nationaler start es überhaupt nicht
kontrollieren können
die eu kann das und die eu muss regeln
aufstellen und zwar wie textilien aus
schauen dass sie recycelbar sind
die deutsche politik zeigt auf europa
und dort ist man schon dabei bis ende
2021 klarere vorgaben für die industrie
auszuarbeiten
doch die allein werden nicht reichen im
moment boomt das geschäft mit der
schnellen mode ungebremst ich frage
nochmal viola wohlgemuth von greenpeace
jeder fast fashion krise der es ernst
meint muss jetzt ein modell vorlegen wie
er aussteigen will hier aussteigen will
von dieser droge fast fashion und
umbauen will zu einem textil
dienstleister an da gibt es so viele
modelle weltweit von kleider leyen
teilen tauschen wir scheren alles
beschert unsere autos unsere musik
unsere filme ist schon längst angekommen
in der bevölkerung ist mit genutzt aber
wo wir das nicht haben ist bei der
textilindustrie kleider teilen und
tauschen noch steckt das modell in den
kinderschuhen aber alternativen zum
klassischen shoppen gibt es längst noch
mal nutzen statt wegwerfen
ich treffe secondhand unternehmer robin
balser im zentrallager seiner firma was
hier hängt nennt sich nicht altkleider
sondern privat oder kraft es sind
kleidungsstücke die weggeworfen wurden
und durch den wiederverkauf wirklich ein
neues leben bekommen
meiner meinung nach sollte man drei vier
fünf jahren erst mal nichts mehr
produzieren und einfach das benutzen was
schon existiert ich glaube jede person
können sich jeden tag mit einem anderen
kleidungsstück anziehen für drei bis
fünf jahre und nichts mehr produziert
wird
vintage ist zum geschäftsmodell geworden
online plattformen für secondhand
sprießen aus dem boden
der globale umsatz soll von 25
milliarden us-dollar 2009 10 auf rund 36
milliarden us dollar bis 2021 steigen
secondhand als lifestyle umweltbewusster
kunden noemi emily und valentin sind
fans von secondhand oder wie man hier
sagt von vintage mode
ich glaube dass vor allem jetzt neue
generation viel viel mehr bewusstsein
hat alles dafür dass man es noch vor
zehn jahren hatte für wo was herkommt
trotzdem denke ich noch nicht dass alle
nur darauf gepolt sind das bin ich auch
nicht
es scheint sich was zu ändern doch im
moment wird secondhand kleidung meist
zusätzlich zur fast fashion gekauft und
ersetzt die noch nicht den hype um die
schnelle mode auf den fast fashion
kaufrausch folgt die altkleider müll
flut und die wird immer weniger
beherrschbar die hersteller versuchen
mit recycling versprechen das gewissen
der kundschaft zu beruhigen
das ist ein marketing trick in
wirklichkeit kann fast fashion niemals
nachhaltig sein
am nachhaltigsten ist immer das
kleidungsstück das gar nicht erst neu
produziert wird
[Musik]